welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boston this is a breakdown of Black Adam
where Dwayne The Rock Johnson aims to
give the rest of the DC Universe a rock
bottom from the rock of Eternity to the
rock of finality truly putting the Rock
in high Rocky force that one hey let's
break down this movie scene by scene for
the Easter eggs and interesting details
that you might have missed and thanks to
boxu for sponsoring this video more on
their tasty offerings later we opened in
2600 BCE the voice of harout explaining
how before Babylon and before the
pyramids were built there was conduct
now the Pyramids of Giza were built from
2589 BC to 2504 BC so 2600 conduct just
made the cut conduct is a fictional
country on Earth in the DC Universe
located near Egypt introduced in 2006 in
Jeff John's 52 series the architecture
of this city of sharuta looks similar to
that 2006 design with the central Palace
and two kneeling statues touching their
fists conduct's original flag had three
triangles which in the comics represent
the pyramid tombs of the wife and sons
of TEF Adam but here they must have some
significance that predates Adam and the
people of conduct continue to embody
this by rallying each other other with
the triangle shape in their hands and
these three triangles being the same
shape of Adriana's eternium necklace and
we made King akhtan played by Marwan
kanzari who also plays his descendant
Ishmael in the present day he already
Bears the inverted pentagram chess
scarring of sabak as her root mentions
his darker Ambitions the camera inverts
showing him upside down hinting at his
desire to enter the mirrored Rock of
finality Underworld the crown of Sabaka
is infused with the powers of the six
Demons of the ancient world the
counterparts to the Wizards of Shazam
and the rock of Eternity these slaves
mine eternium the mineral resource of
conduct that was introduced in the
comics as the shards of matter cast off
by the rock of Eternity when it was
destroyed by Dr savan here it's a
natural mineral something closer to
vibranium and I promise I won't spend
this whole breakdown comparing this to
Black Panther but you gotta admit there
are some obvious parallels here Root's
father tells him to let someone else be
the hero we don't see his face but yeah
this is obviously Dwayne Johnson but it
looks like here his face is mapped onto
a stand-in body one with slightly less
musculature or maybe it's just the rock
like sucking in from everywhere heroots
bravery transports him to the rockaby
eternity chiman hansu returns as a
wizard from the 2019 Shazam film he and
the others Empower heroot with the
stamina of Shu the sweetness of heru the
strength of I'm on the wisdom of zahuti
the power of aten and the courage of
mehen these letters coming together as
Michelle's Shazam sorry about that in
the present day the Smashing Pumpkins
Bullet with Butterfly Wings plays as we
learn that kandak is being plundered by
intergang now the DC Comics intergang is
an international crime syndicate one of
the two major gangs metropolis and her
gang follows the religion of crime
created by Darkseid to spread evil on
Earth so their Tech is alien but here it
is powered on eternium there's actually
a previous nod to enter gang in the dceu
in episode 4 of Peacemaker on that
newspaper below the Gorilla Grodd
headline spilling out Ramon's backpack
are real DC Comics that's DC rebirth
Wonder Woman number one the variant
cover from 2016 Batman Odyssey number
one from 2010 NTC rebirth cyborg number
four from 2016. and like seconds after
this we see there's also an issue from
The Flash kind of like Freddie Freeman
in 2019 Shazam I'm on is a fanboy of the
Justice League and collects these
in-universe comics and posters
mythologizing their heroics and those
just happen to be the same exact comics
and posters from our world it doesn't
totally make sense but whatever it's fun
Adriana and the others drive to this
range high above the Ender gang mines
and refineries paralleling Raiders of
Lost Ark remember how Indy knew that the
Nazis were digging the wrong spot
they're taking you the wrong place
Kareem Pops in a tape marked Jenny
playing baby come back my player so I
guess Jenny must be an ex of his Adriana
Ishmael reached the inner tomb and above
the floating ground of sabakh is this
Cave opening it looks like a lightning
bolt but it's kind of a jagged sloppy
one kind of like how black Adam's chest
sigil is a lightning bolt but it's like
super warm like you know like a like
like acid wash whatever it looks cool
inner gang snatches the crown but
Adriana reads Shazam off the runes to
awaken Adam Adam grabs the chief by the
Nick frying his body with lightning and
only at the end does he snap his neck
finally this is kind of like what Adam
later advises to Amon to make beg for
mercy but deny it until their final
breath as these murks fire on Adam he
ascends it is lightning bolt glows
further and further down his chest to
show how he is gaining power here Adam
swiftly kills all of them I want what he
throws one mercury into another with
that tossberg severed arm still in his
hand he saves Adriana for falling Rebel
and then outside he shoves one
helicopter into the other and we hear
The Rolling Stones Paint It Black as we
watch him move time dilated through the
soldiers in super speed setting to place
all these little dangers on these
trajectories it's a lot like what
Quicksilver does in the time in a bottle
sequence and X-Men Days the Future Past
that's not the MCU you're not allowed to
get mad at me for comparing them Adriana
and Kareem roll up the windows of the
van which seems about as useless as the
kids of Jurassic Park closing the car
door to hide from the T-Rex which I only
bring up because the way this movie
depicts Black Adam is very similar to
the way Kaiju are depicted in films
specifically Warner's monster verse in
the past decade Godzilla and Kong and
Mothra those Titans are not necessarily
evil but they do kind of hover between
chaotic neutral and chaotic good at
times they are awoken from the ancient
world they lay waste to imperialistic
forces they Forge the these bonds with
kids and other lowly humans to become
these gentle giant protectors while
still giving the humans a chance to rise
up as heroes in their own right I really
don't think Black Adam would take it as
an insult to be compared to Godzilla or
King Kong and really
directive the way they set up Godzilla
versus Kong appears to be the same kind
of goal The Rock wants Black Adam vs
Superman and that won't be a battle of
good versus evil necessarily but more of
a WWE style matchup where the fight is
really the spectacle of it Carter Hall
AKA Hawkman watches the footage of this
battle and chats with Amanda Waller and
they assemble the team of the Justice
Society of America starting with Maxine
hunko AKA Cyclone her screen at the gate
lists her aliases Red Tornado born March
1st 1997 5.0 GBA 1600 SAT score favorite
author L frank Baum not to the tornadoes
of the wonderful Wizard of Oz she wears
striped stockings like the Wicked Witch
of the East and rides his bike with a
case on the back you know like Miss
Gulch with a basket on the back of her
bike where she kept Toto I like she's
just really embracing it she actually
later mentions that she was experimented
on by a mad scientist referring to Dr
T.O Moro from the DC Comics next we made
Adam Smasher Al rostain nephew to the
original Adam Smasher played by Henry
Winkler as he's in the comics at Smasher
is a Legacy character and then Kent
Nelson AKA Dr Fate a sorcerer who
carries the helmet a fate called Naboo
now Nabu was the cosmic Lord of order
who arrived at Earth billions of years
in the past to fight the Lords of chaos
so Dr Fate touches this helmet and sees
the vision of Doom and Hawkman dying
impaled this is the Fate that he hopes
to evade But ultimately if you think
about it this does happen either way
Hawkman just uses Nelson's sorcery to
cast a duplicate projection of himself
so it could be argued that Dr Pate was
seeing the true ultimate Fate In This
Moment Carter tells Maxine that his ship
is made entirely out of enth metal down
to the screws so nth metal is an alien
mineral from the planet thanaguard with
gravity-defined properties it composes
his ship parts and his winged armor and
all of his weapons included in his mace
they respond to his mental waves Adam
wakes up in emon's bedroom covered in DC
memorabilia of course Adam accidentally
Burns a hole in the face of the Superman
poster with a sticker in the corner
Reading Rock with a lightning bolt in
the corner clearly the rock is calling
out his next Target the room also has
various Batman posters and one for
Aquaman The Flash Wonder Woman and
specifically the speed race between
Superman and the Flash Kareem watches
The Good the Bad and the Ugly in the
Next Room that's a Sergio Leone Clint
Eastwood Western on KCM a parody of TCM
Turner Classic Movies I'm assuming
conduct classic movies all the Turner TV
stations along with the DC films is
owned by Warner media watching a movie
is about more than just your eyes it's a
full sensory experience the sights the
sounds and the sound ax and if you want
the best movie snacks on the planet
you'll need boxu boxu is a monthly
subscription service that delivers
premium Japanese snacks and tea pairing
straight from Japan to your door they
Source rare snacks from all over the
country and partner with family
businesses to make their own signature
treats all of these are curated and
delivered under a new theme every month
this month's theme is on zucchini
Harvest asukimi is the moon viewing
Festival families gather to Express
gratitude for a good harvest and well
wishes for the next one and that's the
theme of all the great snacks in this
month's box so I'm gonna try this kind
of zawa Earl Gray cake
hmm
oh that's amazing I can't believe they
oh the packaging just keeps it so moist
and fresh every month there's like so
many things in this box that's just like
so delicious and tasty
and really the nice thing about boxu is
that when you really fall in love with
the Box suit snap you can order some
direct from their site at a discount
both I and the new Rockstar's office
have been receiving these boxes for ages
and we love them I've seen some pics
from the office during unboxing and it's
just wild how excited everyone gets plus
every time you get your box to in the
mail you can feel good knowing that
you're supporting family businesses all
the way in Japan if you want to try some
rare Japanese snacks with us click the
link in the description and use the code
rockstars to get 15 off your order now
one thing I really liked about the
second night of this movie is the way
Adam learns from watching TV and he
learns what catch phrases are from this
kid just reminded me a lot of the T800
and Terminator 2 befriending John Connor
Adam floats up at the Statue of teth
Adam and says forgive me not because
he's forgiving himself but because as we
later learned the statue does not depict
him the Shazam Champion form was really
that of his son her root I'm on Laura's
Adam into a fight with the mercenaries a
reenacts the Gunslinger standoff from
The Good the Bad and the Ugly and they
even bring in any even more Coney's
famous music playing over this he zaps
them all in a rapid fire shootout and he
takes two mercenaries up to the sky to
drop them but Hawkman catches them
though Adam just fries the anyway this
leads to a rumble through the streets of
sharuta Hawkman and Adam fight near a
KFC kandaki Fried Chicken oh finger
licking wordplay Adam Smasher actually
later eats a bucket of this stuff before
Dr Fate erases it from his hands I mean
why'd you have to do that you know the
guy needs to recharge come on the JSA
members each try to restrain Adam in
various ways but Adam Smasher finally
catches up to them and punches Adam into
the ground oh Adam Smasher I got it but
Adam Rises and knocks him out meanwhile
I'm on skates past a laundromat called
Big Arm laundry named after the big
severed arm from that statue that
crumpled an ancient conduct this is
severed arm now in the roundabout by the
octone ruins Adriana confronts Adam
about him killing the Wizards who
imprisoned him leaving only the one
played by jaimon hansu a backstory that
we saw in the 2019 Shazam film when
Billy Batson saw an animated form of
Dwayne Johnson fighting the Wizards in
the rock of Eternity now we know exactly
what happened there after Steven I'm on
from ishmael's inner gang mercenaries
Owen's backpack is Left Behind on the
street with Superman comic Pages
flipping in the breeze Adam catches up
to the inner gang biker it tells him you
should be more careful with your word
choice next time and tell them that the
beta blocks at you he's mistakenly
parodying exactly what Eman just told
him earlier in the apartment complex
it's still not quite getting the
catchphrase stuff this leads to a kind
of shell game with I'm owning one of the
hover bikes they're not sure which one
another parallel Raiders lost ark with
Marion in one of the baskets not sure
which one she was in but I'm on ends up
in ishmael's custody Amman says the
champion is coming for me Ishmael says
I'm counting on it and only because this
is DC I just have to shout out the most
over the top delivery from a DC villain
that man will come for me
coming for you
counting on it Hawkman continues to
argue with Adam over killing people
leading to a fight in Elmo's bedroom
Pac-Man's Wings slice a poster of the
flash his mace goes into the face of
Aquaman figurines of Batman and Wonder
Woman just get thrown in the air and
Batman lands on one of them on
skateboards and then Adam's fist goes
through a poster right through the
Superman Crest another dig of the Man of
Steel but when Adam's hand pushes
through Emma's hiding spot where the
crown is kept that eternium repels
Adam's Fist and on the other side of
that folding drawer is a Superman action
figure aha so we see the one member of
the Justice League in this room able to
stop Adam is Superman they fly into the
mine to save Ammon Black Adam Leroy
Jenkins is the head of the others is all
set to Kanye's power boo but if
ishmael's plan was for Adam to kill him
upon getting that Crown I kind of feel
bad for all these inter-gang guys that
Ishmael said it for Adam to clobber his
way through to get him here I mean I
feel kind of bad they're they are
colonizers they give Ishmael the crown
and Ishmael reveals that he is a
descendant of King Octon and he says
death is the only path to life a
reversal of Adriana's translation of the
inscription Ishmael pulls the trigger
and blocks the bullet and Fries him as
he clutches the crown in his chest and
Adam reveals that he wasn't the true
champion his son who root was garud's
adult Champion form is played by early
Logic kefu the Australian Tongan actor
who plays young rock on that NBC sitcom
it's surely perfect casting I love that
they got him for this but root
transferred his powers to his father
turning him into the Rock they say
Shazam at the same time it's very sad we
are root this leaves her root vulnerable
to Acton's archers so back at the
present Adam D powers and surrenders to
be taken to wallers task force x black
sight and an icy Mountain Lake they are
greeted by Amelia Harcourt Jennifer
Holland making a cameo after the suicide
squad and Peacemaker she says you know
they say the gods created us but we're
the ones who always wind up burying them
I love this line because it might hint
at their arrangement with Kal-El a God
that they recently buried but
nonetheless resurrected and is now
helping them bury all these other gods
Adam is placed in suspended animation
alongside dozens of other meta-humans
reminds me a lot of those human pods in
The Matrix but yeah this tells us that
task force x has several god-level
meta-humans in captivity that are all
too powerful to be kept in prisons like
Bell Reeves based on Superman's timing
in that post-credits scene arriving just
after Waller says she'd send someone
Adam's way I really think Halal may have
been the one to help Waller and Harcourt
hunt down all these metahumans which
tells us that Superman isn't the same
Boy Scout these days or if he is a Boy
Scout he's the kind of Boy Scout who
gets all his other boy scout friends
arrested I mean I was at Eagle Scouts
Scouts trustworthy loyal helpful
friendly Curtis kind of eating cheerful
thirsty Brave clean Reverend and loyal's
the second one of those Al gives I'm on
a red JSA shirt to wear his a cape so
that he looks like Captain Underpants
for the rest of the movie I mean
whatever these movies are made for kids
and I'm a man who gets weird thoughts
about what part of Adam smasher's crotch
Cyclone ran across earlier Kent recalls
being a kid watching RAF Pilots March
toward the Western Front referring to
World War II he says his fate Powers
have let him live longer than most men
do Pierce Brosnan is 69 but to have
memories of World War II Camp would have
to be at least like 84 or 85. I just
like that his character is a lot older
than he looks and he's just been good at
keeping it tight but taped with his mind
Adriana realizes that the inscription on
the crown is really death is the only
path to life we see ishmael's soul in
the rock of finality that is the mirror
realm to the rock of Eternity in the DC
Comics Reign and lava naturally drip
upward here and instead of Shazam
Ishmael mutter's sabak and he resurrects
for the powers of the six Demons of the
rock of finality and becomes sabak Dr
Faith prevents the other members of the
JSA from helping him fight sabak alone
this fight is pretty wild with each
Doctor Fate projection sabot kills the
camera pulls back from the golden helmet
of another projection from helmet to
helmet to helmet until it Glides into
the helmet of the real Kent who
simultaneously astral projects to Adam
back at the black site the amount of
mental focus required to multitask like
this it's just hurting my brain daddy
fate is a true MVP of this movie we
undercut from teth Adam fighting task
force sex security to subach fighting
through the Fate projections as if each
kill is the kind of countdown two
Champions clawing closer and closer to
their goal line and they both get there
the Box sits on the throne unleashing
the legions of Hell to fight the people
of conduct and Adam reaches the surface
to say Shazam he joins the fight Hawkman
stabs the Box through the shoulder and
he gets stabbed himself fulfilling Dr
Pete's Vision but it reveals to be a
projection trick that he learned from Dr
Fate and that this helmet when his eyes
light up is continuing to Aid them Adam
finally gets the catchphrase right tell
them the man in Black sent you and he
rips the pocket freaking half from the
horns down and the catchphrase was never
more appropriate than right now because
Ishmael is returning to the Rock finale
that it faced the six demons who will
want to know what happened now he's got
an answer for him Black Adam takes the
throne but says it feels wrong so he
smashes it and he says conduct does not
need a hero it has enough Heroes but he
will stick around as a protector kinda
like Godzilla every Godzilla needs a
Kong to challenge him for the throne
right it's just nature and speaking of
Superman I go into that fully in my post
credit scene breakdown and really the
fascinating story of how they were able
to pull off getting Henry Cavill to do
this you can follow me on Tick Tock
Instagram and Twitter at hey boss follow
the new Rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]